[Music]
[Applause]
uh this is awesome i'm so glad to be
here i'm also going to disappoint you
because today i won't be
flying drones with bananas
i will not do a psychological experiment
on you i really enjoyed those
yesterday
i won't be talking about css either
because in my talk i want to focus
specifically on html
html is that language that most people
will check the checkbox in their cv and
they will say well i know my html
but you know it's got a lot of power uh
html is a really cool thing and it's
actually quite a complex beast as well
so html enables a lot of things that we
all like such as the multi-device web so
the fact that we have the web work on so
many different devices like when the web
was invented now it's just this really
all the machine
that we now would consider like old
and now we use the web on phones and on
our watches and the reason that that's
possible is that we can write css
and the reason that we can write css is
that we have a structure to program our
css against which is html html makes all
of that possible it enables also
default style sheets in other browsers
and you'd be surprised if you look at
what sort of default styles a browser
will apply to your website i know we
love to reset our css but there's a lot
of stuff that the default style sheet
will actually make possible such as like
if you have a table and you want to
position two things next to each other
the default style sheet has you covered
um there's problems by heading i'll get
into that in a minute
and there is a default behavior for
instance when you have buttons they are
going to submit a form for you if you
put them in a form and you use the
default type uh it enables reader modes
which is something that people with adhd
love to use but those all of us love to
use that in these days because websites
get more and more complicated
so yeah i have a font love for for html
as well i just said um maybe we should
stop doing javascript let's focus on
html my token score is the market that
matters
and i want to tell you in this next 30
minutes about you know why i think
markup is important and how it can help
users to enjoy the web more
all right
thanks for coming to my talk this was
great
um no i i'll introduce myself i'm hitta
i work at developer relations uh in
sanity insanity
we are a platform for structured content
we basically have as our mission to make
it easier for
website owners to have content for
content creators to create it and for
developers to work with it
to ultimately create better websites
more interesting websites too
i also blog on here.vlog you can like
and subscribe there i've got an rss feed
if you're into that
and you can follow me on twitter i'll
put the slides there afterwards um i
have a lot of links in this and a lot of
things that i can't explain in detail
they are
in my slide act that i'll be posting
after this talk
um so yeah let's talk about
accessibility
i mean we've heard adrian yesterday
explain that what accessibility is i'll
do my definition too uh it is to ensure
that people with disabilities can use
your site or your app
now the way that i like to rephrase it
is that this also means that people with
disabilities can buy our product that
they can spend money at your company or
that they can use a service
now this is important because it
concerns a lot of people
that you might not add to the
accessibility category immediately
instead of like neurological conditions
and motor impairments
deafness blindness lots of different
things uh are all disabilities that
means that a lot of people do things
like using high contrast mode
so that they can see content more easily
it is that people zoom in on websites
because they have low vision uh it is
the fifa reduced motion uh because they
could get physically sick of uh of
motion uh it is that sometimes people
don't use a mouse uh that could be
because they prefer to use a keyboard it
could be because they can't handle a
mouse because of all sorts of conditions
so basically lots of reasons that
different people experience the web in a
different way
now our focus today about
specifically on people who use assistive
technologies
not because they're the most important
category but because that's where we can
have most impact as developers this is
the part where we have a huge impact
on people for instance who use voice
control to control their computers uh
people use a free display that converts
what happens on the screen in supreme in
real time really cool technology uh
people who use voice over uh like
technologies like screen readers that
will read out everything that happens on
your screen
so yeah lots of interesting technologies
that are all powered ultimately by our
markup
how does that work well
uh you're probably all familiar with the
document object model
if you go to a website and
you request the website the server is
going to respond with markup and the
browser is going to turn that into a
tree the dom tree
now what some people don't know is that
there is a secondary tree which is the
accessibility tree and browsers will
generate that so that they can mark
things like hey here's a radio button
that's called round trip you can select
it and press it here's a slider that can
go between 0 and 24.
it's 7 at the moment and it's called
departure time and you can increment and
decrement it uh here's a button that
search and you can press it
now when you hear that you might be able
to imagine like a visual interface for
this sort of thing um maybe you have one
in your head you can design one but this
is also the information that these
assistive technologies will use in order
to provide an interface for
users with disabilities so in a way that
it works for them
now the way that that works is uh it
generates an accessibility three and
that answers questions like what kind of
thing is this
uh so is it a button or is it a link or
is it an input type and that's called
the role so you'll find that in the
accessibility tree
then there is how should we refer to it
that's the accessible name so it's
things like this is called departure
time or here is your save details button
or here's your click here link
and then there's a bunch of meta
information
like is this thing expanded or is this
checkbox checked
so that sort of information is there too
so this accessibility tree uh is on
every website regardless of whether you
wanted to or not so it's going to base
that on the dom tree and it's going to
exist so when i ordered website for
accessibility
i'll be looking for this information so
let's say i'm on a news website i see a
bunch of links in the top so i'll go
there and have a look like oh here we
see a raw link and it's called worlds
it's going to take us to world news uh
here's a real link that's called u.s
politics let's give that one
a role link that's called business and
then there's a role button that's called
edition maybe i can switch editions
there or something like that
now that information exists on every
website and i use that to figure out if
my website is accessible or not or my
clients
so basically how this works is as i
explained your markup will generate a
dom tree in the browser
and then that's going to generate an
accessibility tree
now from that point on that information
is passed on to so-called platform apis
and they exist on all the big platforms
so they're on windows they're on mac
they're on mobile phones and these
platforms ultimately integrate with
assistive technologies
yeah so
technologies such as rereaders very
displays look at their information from
there
now you can also get this information by
looking in your browser so chromium
firefox safari they all expose this
information you may have come across it
as well
so if you see roles you see names that's
all information from your accessibility
tree
so yeah it's the markup that matters
and let's talk about what that means in
practice
with the following examples it doesn't
matter of what sort of framework you use
what do you like to output your html
because ultimately it's all going to be
html and it's all going to be double
trees
so that's what we care about here now
your markup can answer questions like
where am i so when a user of a screen
reader comes to your page it's going to
read out the title element that is
inside your web app
so whether you touch this or not like
this could be living in some template
that you never look at
um
it could be like in a single page
application where it never changes but
you want to make sure there's something
unique there's a really cool video with
leonie watson
a friend who is an accessibility expert
and screen reader user and she explains
that video that when she ends up on a
website this is what confirms to her
that she's in the right place so if
she's shopping
online this is how she knows whether
she's like in the vegetable department
or in the clothing department like this
is the information she needs to know am
i on the right page
um
there is questions like what is
omnispace which are answered by headings
so h1 h2 h3 whenever you use these know
that they are used by readables but they
are also used by a mechanism called
navigate by heading so in screen readers
most often users will start with this so
they will look for a list of headings
which you can pull up in some square
units you'll press the hp
and then you'll jump kind of between
headings it's a bit like when you call a
customer service
and they go like press one for support
press two for sales
you'll kind of be redirected to the
right place that happens here too but
with your heading structure so your
headings are used for this kind of
mechanism so you want to make sure that
the information that's in there is
helpful
this is a heading i found on a marketing
website
it says every detail counts
now i don't know what i'm gonna find
there so if this is presented to me i
don't know where i'm going to end up
what would have been a good header there
is something like specifications because
it went to the specifications section so
the words you put in there are are
important i know this is not strictly
developer but yeah
another question that your markup can
answer is which areas are on this page
so um
there is this phenomenon called
landmarks and they let you specify what
sort of thing is in your website what
kind of sections so yesterday when we uh
came into this auditorium the organizers
were telling us like this is where the
toilets are this is where the community
space is so they've basically given us
some landmarks for this very venue
and this is what you can do too for your
website or for your web page really like
it's perfect and you want to say like
this is where my header is this is where
my footer is
um i won't go into too much detail on
how landmarks work but one thing that's
important to know uh is that you don't
want to have too many of them so in this
case we don't want to have a landmark
for every chair that's in this
auditorium that would be rather annoying
like it's really hard to then find uh
what you're looking for um there's a lot
more detail in the post by school kohara
called accessible landmarks that i'll be
linking out to i think landmarks are a
really cool way for people to navigate
around a page in addition to headings
and if once and this is embarrassingly
me closing myself um
i did a presentation on what browsers
could do to make it
easier to
do accessibility and one of the things
that i mocked up for that was wouldn't
it be nice if we could see landmarks in
the browser so that we could actually
look at that
there are some plugins that do that but
i think it would be cool if that was
exposed by default so that people could
all like navigate around websites like
that and without kind of relying on the
user interface so they could see like oh
these are the most viewed articles on
this webpage now for this mock-up i had
to make up the landmarks because they
weren't actually there in the face that
i used as an example
but yeah maybe that would improve
in that way
something else that has a huge impact on
web accessibility is form controls uh i
won't go into too much detail but one
thing i want to highlight is naming
their instance non-profit from the us
that looks at the top 1 million websites
automatically
it does some automated checking
and it found in 2022
that almost half of the inputs on the
web or on the web pages that they looked
at were not properly labeled so they
were basically missing the accessible
name part in the accessibility tree so
what this means is that stuff like input
fields radio buttons checkboxes all of
that
were left without the name
now this can easily happen right you
might build a user interface where
someone needs to input a city
and you'll have the word sitting there
you'll have the input and then you look
at the accessibility screen and you'll
find that the role for this input is
text box or entry that's good that's
what we're looking for you get that for
free with uh uh input type um but then
the name is no or empty string and the
reason for that is that there's no
connection between that word city that
we can visually see
and the input that is right next to it
so the reason uh we want to label this
is to make sure that in the
accessibility tree there is also an
accessible name available
now there's this whole algorithm called
the accessible name and
description computations specification
uh it exists somewhere on the w3c
website uh and it has information on
exactly how names are calculated there's
lots of ways that the browser will try
and figure out like what is this input
for but one way that you can do it is to
have a label element with the four
attributes that refers to the id of the
inputs so they're both city in this case
so they refer to each other and that's
now
a properly named input
then i want to mention table semantics
um because there are some fills around
that fables are bad for accessibility
they can actually be really good for
tavern data so if you have data that you
want to display tables make those easier
to navigate for people with assistive
tag
if you use the right semantics and one
thing i want to focus on is the caption
that is there so let's say you're
building like a financial website i'm
obviously not in finance
but let's say you have like two tables
and one is for 2018 financial results
and the other is for 2019 then this is
how you distinguish between the two you
add a caption and then when someone with
a screen reader goes to that webpage
they'll be able to find the difference
between these tables now these are
simple they have two rows
but i spoke to someone who was white and
was doing an internship at deloitte and
he was looking at lots of tables every
day
and he actually struggled with this
because he had to go really deep down
into
the tables to figure out oh this is
actually the 2018 one i'm not looking
for this one so
again a caption is like a landmark type
of thing or like a heading that says hey
you need to be here
for this information
and then i want to add with buttons
they are awesome for accessibility
so whenever you use a button people can
find it in the tap order they can press
it with the keyboard and they can submit
the form even if they ask fails which is
nice like that's a cool default behavior
sometimes people build buttons with divs
that's a lot harder to do
i won't blame you if you do it but it's
just a lot harder and there's a lot of
stuff that browsers do that you might
not notice um like keyboard behavior and
like there's a lot of things i wouldn't
even know from the top of my head what
sort of things to optimize for so the
button element is great
there's something special going on when
you have just icons inside of your
buttons because you know where does the
accessible name come from
if you have the button it probably has
something like an svg right in there and
the browser doesn't know what's on this
svg
in this case you might recognize it
from some apps then you will be able to
add a reaction there
so that's what we are looking for here
but when we look at this in the
accessibility tree we'll have a button
role so that's good but we have a name
again of empty string
now one way to do that is to add a real
label to the button and that way we say
this is the add reaction button it's
going to show up in the accessibility
tree it's going to overwrite everything
that's inside of that so the svg that's
inside of there
is actually going to be ignored it has
no value for the naming but if there was
text in there it would also get ignored
so area label overrides all of that you
could also add a span in there and then
put the content there but if you don't
want that visual you need to visually
hide it so you need to fly some css that
does not display not on or visibility
hidden
now i love to refer people to this it's
the html specification specifically for
developers so html is where browser
makers go to figure out how html is
supposed to work it's a really good
resource but it has a lot of browser
specific information so this thing has
that taken out and it's specifically for
developers it has lots of examples i go
to it all the time especially when i do
accessibility audits just to make sure
that what i'm telling developers
actually is what is in this
specification
another great website is htm hell by my
friend manuel matuso
you know if you're used to the name it
is actually really nice uh it's got a
lot of examples of stuff that random
people found on the web like usage of
html that they don't agree with
and inside of that there is also
explanations of what could have been
better instead so i recommend that too
so we've talked about a lot of ways to
use markup to do accessibility but
obviously we're really interested in
javascript here
and the good news is that there's some
work happening at the w3c to take some
of this stuff to javascript
in an effort called accessibility object
model
now this is a collection of different
specifications and web platform features
that would allow you to use javascript
to impact accessibility trees
and to read them as well
this is exciting some of this is not
available yet some of it is being
experimented with
but i thought it would be interesting to
highlight it and maybe in a few years
this is what we are using all day
one of the things that
aeom is supposed to do is allow you to
set accessibility information with ivl
properties so that means when you have a
dom element you can set dot role
set the property to button or you could
set area disabled as a property this is
similar to doing set attribute and doing
it with an attribute very similar but
now we're doing it directly on the
element
now this is user visible and user
modifiable which means that if you look
in your devtools you'll actually see it
update in a dom
there is another thing that is being
talked about and experimented within
chromium which is setting this stuff
internally so you put it inside a
lowercase internals object
and that will make it kind of part of
the element that you're building so this
is relevant for people building web
components
you'll be setting the role directly in
your components meaning that the person
who is going to use that component
cannot change it because it's like fake
thin
and that can be useful when you're doing
like design systems and you want to make
sure that the accessibility is
exactly as you had
expected it
there's also some work happening around
relationships with altitrafs i showed
the example before with a label and an
input
and this requires you to point from the
one element to the other
that doesn't always work especially in
the context of
web components because then you have
shadow boundaries and they don't go
across that so you can't
refer to another element
of an id that's inside or outside of the
shadow binary that doesn't work so
there's some proposals there um
a thing called the crossroad area
delegation api um
read the explainer it's really
interesting what they are what they are
working on there
another part of aom that's interesting
is events from assistive technologies
this seems like a really cool plan so
you would be able as a developer to know
hey someone has used voice over to click
on this thing or they've gonna use their
screen reader to navigate here
but very quickly people found out hey
this doesn't actually meet the privacy
requirements
if that information is available to
developers it is also available to
anyone who wants to collect data on
users and you know that's bad so the
alternative is synthesized dom events
and a lot of that is already in place
now they are documenting it
so that means that stuff like a
voiceover has clicked on this or your
voice control thing has clicked on it it
will just look like a click event so as
a developer you don't know what the
difference is and how the click has
happened you just get a click event uh
there
so that kind of works and then the last
part of am is reading accessibility tree
from javascript i think that's really
exciting because it allows for better
testing
currently when you want to test area
attributes you want to read the
attributes that are available in the dom
and with this you could look at the
computer stuff so whatever the browser
has decided a name is going to be or
whatever the browser has decided the
role is going to be it could be helpful
when you have like two roles on an
element which you shouldn't have but you
know bugs exist
so you might be able to find bugs more
easily that way
right so going from
uh
doing that in javascript i want to go
back to doing that kind of as part of
html as part of the the web platform as
tiger said earlier today it is great to
use the power of the web platform uh
he's using that obviously for home
automation uh that is awesome i use it
as well but for accessibility uh because
you know html comes with a lot of
accessibility built in uh i'm obviously
excited about that the stuff that i've
shown shows that like html has all of
that stuff but the problem is that there
isn't html for everything so quite often
we want to build stuff that doesn't
actually exist in html or maybe it does
exist like a fake picker there's input
type equals date
but it isn't very good or it isn't the
way that you want it to be it isn't
styleable or it doesn't have the
features that you want
um you know and we've all been there
before kind of filthy figures and and
done this sort of thing uh it's a lot of
work and it's really hard to get it
right uh so there's another effort in
the w3c called open ui which was started
by nicole jonathan from google and greg
whitford he was at microsoft and he said
salesforce now
and the goal of open ui is basically to
make it unnecessary to reinvent your own
controls so this group is working on a
lot of primitives that will come to the
web
and that you can use to build your own
controls that will make it easier to to
customize stuff so that you don't need
to start with divs and
make really complex things but then you
can actually
build it with html that is really
purposefully made for that
now i'm really excited because i think
standardized controls can be a really
big opportunity for accessibility i was
talking to one someone yesterday who was
working on a design system and we talked
about how like design systems are
awesome for propagating the right thing
so if you have a really good design it's
gonna propagate
also if you have really good
accessibility it's going to propagate
because people are reusing your
accessibility that is really good
if you do it badly though like your bad
stuff is also going to be reduced and
it's going to propagate badly so this is
you know a moment of choice you want to
really make sure that you're doing it
well and that's definitely the case for
components that we're bringing to the
web platform because once it's in html
it cannot leave like
all the stuff that's in html has been
there forever sometimes stuff gets
deprecated but it's a long process and
we've got to make sure that it doesn't
exist on any major websites because it
will break the web now this work is
happening uh nicole sullivan tweets
about that sometimes uh she shares in
this thing that it would be really cool
uh if you have something like implied
accessibility semantics so try and cover
all of the accessibility phases in these
open ui elements um which you know he
says it's really hard to get right but
if we do it it's a chef's case
and i totally agree with that like it's
hard to do but if we are able to then i
think that could be huge for for
accessibility
so i have two open ui things that i want
to share and that are
to me could be the future of of html one
is select menu
who has ever tried to customize a
selector i see some hands maybe
yes i can't see it very well but i think
i see a lot of head hands going up there
um a lot of people have greg wooford
talked to a lot of developers and did a
survey at jscon of berlin and asked like
how do you all feel about doing a custom
select and people didn't feel super
happy like it's hard to build search and
list ui kind of things there's a lot of
things that you can't customize
and a lot of people want to put
arbitrary html there like have some
images with your options maybe you have
like avatars or
other stuff logos that you want to have
show up there and that sort of thing is
not possible with current select right
you'll have select so you have some
options and you got the browser ui
now there's a lot of benefits to that
like if i open this on my phone
then i get an interface that's really
like made for my phone so that's nice
and you couldn't do that with a
component you feel yourself that's a bit
harder
but other than that like i want to
actually be able to spell the insides of
this like i want to add maybe a shadow
and make it pink or do something like a
background image and that sort of thing
isn't possible today with selects
now there is a proposal called select
menu which basically is a bit like
select but you call it select menu for
reasons like we couldn't extend the
existing select for this
for reasons again
um but what this would allow you to do
is sell the select and a bunch of other
things uh like replace the html that is
inside of that
uh i'll not go into that but i'll show
you how you would sell that so in css
you would get a pseudo class that would
allow you to sell apart
and then you can say which fire you want
to sell so you can style the button or
the list box or the selected value even
so basically all of the parts are
available for you to style just like you
would style divs and at that point a lot
of them at least that's the hope from
open ui side of things a lot of the
reasons to make your own select kind of
disappear because you are now able to do
a lot of styling and if you can replace
markup then yeah you can do a lot more
there too
now this i'll do a browser supporting
this is still in discussion right so a
lot of this thing
is still
being discussed it's experimental but it
exists now behind flags so you can play
with it in chromium in edge and chrome
if you turn on the experimental web
features flag
there is some accessibility issues still
with it but you know it's promising and
i think it'd be really interesting to
hear what all of you think when you play
with it
now the second element i want to mention
is the pop-up attributes previously
known as the fluff of elements
pop-ups are things like what we see here
this is in the sanity ui
where you upload uh an image and you got
like the little action menu where you
can do stuff like delete the image or
you know interact with it
now this kind of thing is currently
often built with this because it's
really hard to like add icons we have a
heading in there there's like a few
lines and different colors that sort of
thing you can't do with current select
but you might be able to do it with
pop-up
now fluff flips are things like action
menus also ui to teach stuff
content pickers like that calendar stuff
that we looked at earlier
suggestions for form elements and also
the select that we talked about earlier
now the behavior that these things have
in common is that they exist on top of
other page content
so they are in this so-called top layer
that the browser will ship with that
means you don't need to worry about that
index and try and position it above
everything else
because the top layer will take care of
that for you unless you put a lot of
stuff in that then and you still have
some connections to deal with um it is
only open when it needs to be right so
when you click the button to open it
that's open and then you close it again
and it's usually one of the time so
there's also some discussions around
like this missing this automatically
like when you click outside of your
profile
so let's look at how that would work if
the current proposals go ahead so this
is all very much in flux we meet every
thursday evening
about this and sometimes we change
attribute names and stuff but you know
you would fill something like the pop-up
with maybe a div a heading and some
buttons
then you add the pop-up attribute and
now you have a pop-up now what this is
is that it's going to hide it by default
so when the browser loads this the user
agent style sheet will take care of it
for you it's going to hide the pop-up
and then when you call a javascript
method you can then open the pop-up
which will then open it or you can do it
declaratively
as well
so you would set an id and then you can
add a button that has a total of
attributes and that version is now going
to toggle that software for you so
basically the contact menu we have there
could be this button
and then it could open the there for you
and close it again
there's also a high fluff up and a shelf
of attributes in place so that you could
do only one of the things if that's
something that you need
now this is just pop-up on its own as an
attribute uh the default value for that
is auto
which is the thing we see here
another value would be async and that
would be something like that we've
previously talked about as toast
so it would be like a warning or um
something like a success message so here
in santa fe ui if you've uploaded an
image or something like that it's going
to tell you that the upload was
successful
so you can do that with fluff equals
anything uh there's still some talk
about like should that have area rules
to announce it and stuff like that maybe
that will uh that will happen uh so
basically you find that in javascript
you do your publishing magic like in our
case we run it through the api and then
put it back and stuff like that we'll
get a message at some point
and then we set the text content to
something that we want and then we show
the flip up that's basically how that
works
and then it's going to show that and the
browser will take care of placing this
on top of everything else and that sort
of thing
this is also available behind flags this
syntax has only shipped in canary a few
days ago so if you find it doesn't work
that might be because you haven't
updated canary it's super recent but
again we would love your thoughts on it
um open ui is on twitter and you can
find us there and we'll tweet out like
questions
in this group there's a lot of uh
browser makers and i'm really looking
forward to hear in fact from actual
developers to know like you know does
this make sense uh are the attributes
wrong uh let us know you can find us on
discord as well and there's weekly
meetings and they're also open to attend
for everyone
all right so
let's wrap up
i'm a little over time
the one thing i've talked about today is
that markup affects accessibility trees
every one of you generates markup at
some point unless everything you do is
on the canvas but you know there's still
going to be some markup somewhere it's
going to generate accessibility trees
and that's going to in fact end users
is coming to javascript land it's nice i
can play with it in javascript and some
of it might be coming to new built-in
html elements
now i'm looking forward to the future
for now you know love your html
look at this fact because there's lots
of useful information there
to use html to the max and you know use
the power of the of the web platform
now thanks very much for listening that
was all for me slides will be available
on
that url also tweet it if that's too too
long
and with that yeah thanks very much for
having me